[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISAAC HEPWORTH: Hi, I'm Isaac.
In this video, I'm going to give
you an overview of Apigee's API
monitoring capabilities.
APIs are the foundation of
modern connected applications.
From mobile banking
to self-driving cars,
from retail to
health care, nearly
every digital interaction
today is underpinned by APIs.
Therefore, API
service degradations
can directly impact your
customers' experience,
your reputation, and
even your revenue.
To ensure seamless
connected experiences
for developers,
customers, and partners,
operations teams today want
to assure API service quality,
proactively identify API
issues before customers do,
quickly diagnose
those issues, and take
appropriate remedial
actions fast.
All of these capabilities are
available through the Apigee
Edge platform to empower
your operations teams
and increase API reliability.
Let me show you.
Apigee API monitoring
can alert you
to live issues via
Slack, PagerDuty,
or in this case, email.
Clicking through, you can see
the alert details, including
a link to a playbook
that recommends
remedial action for this
particular type of issue.
Your playbook could be a wiki
page, a diagnostics manual,
a triage flowchart, or
other relevant documentation
of your choice.
Let's go a little deeper here.
Clicking through,
you are now taken
to a rich, contextual view of
the error and the circumstances
surrounding it.
In the first section, you
can find the basic condition
details, and again, a
link to the playbook.
Scrolling down, you can see
these powerful co-occurrence
matrices, two-dimensional
views that
allow you to quickly visualize
and pinpoint the nature
and source of the error.
Operations teams can often
spend hours navigating
multiple systems to
gather and cross-correlate
this information, but
Apigee API monitoring
can provide it for you
in just a few clicks.
You can also click the
report icon on the right
to generate a custom report.
You'll see it's already
pre-populated with just
the right set of filters
specific to this error
condition to help
others investigate
a similar issue faster.
From here, click on the
menu button on the right
to navigate to
the timeline view.
This gives the ability to view
the performance of components
of your API system over time.
For this particular proxy,
we're looking at the past three
months of activity.
Creating an alert trigger in
Apigee Edge is straightforward.
In the monitoring dashboard,
click on Alerts, and then
the button to add an alert.
You can specify the condition.
You can set thresholds
or add dimensions.
And under dimensions,
you can also
select a collection
of interests.
A collection is a grouping
of proxies and targets
that you want to monitor
closely as a unit.
Apigee API monitoring
lets you see
a snapshot of
historical condition
data overlaid with
your thresholds
to set just the right values.
This is just a quick sample.
To get these monitoring
capabilities for your traffic,
all you need to do is
to create an Apigee
Edge, a proxy for your APIs,
and direct client applications
to use it.
And of course, all of
the data presented here
is available via our own
APIs, so you can connect it
to your analysis, audit, and
service management tools.
OK.
That's a quick introduction
to Apigee Edge API monitoring.
It provides contextual
insights into API performance,
helps quickly diagnose
issues, and facilitates
remedial actions for service
assurance and business
continuity.
If you want to know more, dive
into the product documentation
or visit the community.
That's it from me.
Until next time, keep
those APIs running.
[MUSIC PLAYING]